When things aren't going well, you have
to be your own biggest fan.
>> Yes. Yes.
>> And when things are going well, you have
to be your own biggest critic. And it's
a very different
>> state of mind to be very different.
Right.
>> Well, and also, you know, and and
especially because like you don't want
to be deputy downer in your company
going, "Wow, but like who else is,
right?"
This is Dalton plus Michael and today
we're going to talk about the problems
that growth doesn't solve. So, we've
been accused of telling founders just
grow, grow, grow, grow, grow. And we're
not um retracting that advice.
>> However,
>> there's some nuance. There's some
nuance. There's nuance. So, let's go
through some of that nuance here.
>> Growth does solve a whole lot of
problems. Often, when someone is dealing
with burnout
>> or they're dealing with we can't raise
money.
>> Oh, yeah.
>> Like there's just a whole set of
problems where if you the actual fix is
just to grow.
>> Yes. And then suddenly this money
problem, oh that just got fixed. And
suddenly the motivation or the burnout
problem gets fixed. So growth is very
good and does fix a whole lot of
problems.
>> We're not knocking growth. We're not
saying oh like like being rich has a lot
of problems like yeah but it's
>> so so growth is still good but there's
some nuance here that we wanted to talk
about and and part of the reason we we
were discussing why to make a video
about this. I think it's that there are
AI related companies right now
>> that are seeing incredible growth,
>> shocking growth,
>> and
perhaps
that doesn't solve all of their
problems. You know, there's always this
dichotomy in mind because, you know, you
work with YC companies during the batch
and you're just like, let's get a graph
that goes up to the right. Let's get a
graph that goes up to the right. All we
have to do to convince an investor to
invest in you is to convince them that
this trend that's already happening will
continue.
And
while I think that is still very good
advice, I think for founders who are
kind of experiencing growth, there's
some questions that we want them to ask
themselves. There's some things that we
want them to dig into because
unfortunately and especially what's
interesting to me is that
there's a phase of growth that's kind of
dangerous. I I'll I'll put too big of an
error bar around it and you tell me what
you think. Right. I think between a
million in revenue and a 100 million in
revenue. That is a very dangerous error
bar. That's a very dangerous zone
because I think companies in that zone
just raw assume anything that's
happening that's going well will
continue until they pass through that
zone until let's call it preipo zone
whereas you and I know and like you know
I think is general knowledge that ever
come every a million dollars in revenue
does not IPO right and so it's like we
know all of the death stories that
happen in that zone y and there's
probably one more zone in the 100 to 500
and then like you things are are are
more predictable. And so when founders
are in that kind of that first zone and
they're just like, man, we're making it.
What are some of the questions you tell
them to ask themselves?
>> Okay. Well, one classic one um is the
old uh unit economics thing. And so this
is the
>> if you give away stuff for free that
costs you money, like let's say you had
a website where that was like free money
website.
>> Yes. um that would grow like people
would go to that website, they would pay
[laughter] me 75 cents, I'll give you a
dollar revenue through the
>> Yeah, you can you can reliably grow.
>> Yes.
>> Um losing money and again you could be
like well
>> economies of scale
>> and that's and that's fair there there's
there are certainly very educated
sophisticated strategies around
>> Yes.
>> losing money to get something off the
ground.
>> Yes. But by and large, just growing
faster doesn't mean you're going to
solve uneconomic issues. Like it's not
self-evident. We see more companies die
by assuming that there are economies of
scale without deeply probing it. Yeah.
And discovering that perhaps in their
company those economies of scale never
arose.
>> Yeah. This is a hard thing to just
handwave. Yeah. Um, again to give
another just like classic textbook
example, it's where you get growth by
spending a lot of money on ads.
>> Yes.
>> And you're like, "Oh, yeah. Yeah." You
know, like the payback period is going
to be great. You know, we don't have any
retention data yet, but this is going to
be fine.
>> Yes.
>> That's a classic one where actually a
ton of adup supported growth
doesn't mean all of your problems are
solved. You might still have problems.
>> I mean, and I'll go one step further.
When you see people who are using
marketing and they're like, "Well, the
marketing numbers at this scale, my CAC,
my cost to acquire a customer at this
scale will remain if I 100x my marketing
budget." And it's like, I've never seen
that. [laughter]
And so like [clears throat]
the assumptions around unit economics at
small scale need to be reassessed at
every order of magnitude scale because
oftentimes they change. It's interesting
to watch people realize that their
products become more exp like the
internet economies get worse as they
scale because they have all these hidden
costs. Indeed, customer service fraud is
one that bites people [laughter] that
you never see. If you get successful
enough that fraud rings spend a lot of
time attacking your startup, it's a high
class problem. Again, like if you're
lucky enough that there's a lot of
people professionally trying to rip you
off, it means you did something good.
>> But, but man, that's hard.
>> That's really hard. That's really,
really hard. Okay. So, unit economics,
that's a big one. Uh, where would you go
next? Is
>> I think Moes, again, this is one of
those things that likely
uh some people are annoyed of hearing
about like, yeah, yeah, Moes, whatever.
But I think it's just
>> we've seen people grow really, really,
really fast and have no clue how to make
it defensible or what how they'll
prevent I always use this thought
experiment. Why won't there be some YC
company in the next batch?
>> Yeah.
>> That sees that your thing is working and
then just does the same thing. like what
prevents them from
just taking your customers? I mean,
historically, the canonical example of
this was adte where it was kind of like,
oh, I'm this thin layer between like a
whole bunch of customers and a super big
social media site, right?
This is sustainable.
>> Yeah.
>> And like the social super big social
media is like sites like maybe I want a
direct relationship with my customer.
>> Yeah. It's this.
>> And so again, the point here is not that
you must have an A+ perfect answer all
the time. No, no, we're not just saying
saying that. We're just saying
>> it is not self-evident that because you
are growing fast,
>> you have a mode.
>> That you have a mode. Those are not
>> yes. [laughter] Yes.
>> You know,
>> and I think like that just means probe.
>> Probe ask yourself the hard question.
>> Yeah. Don't don't let the future YC
company probe you. No. [laughter]
Well, and this might be a point to to
make an interesting aside here.
Maybe the meta reason why we're telling
you to do these things is because others
won't.
>> Yeah.
>> Like that investor that's seeing the
revenue go up to the right, they're
going to be like, "Great. Those
employees, great." Like often times the
press, great. Like, like when you're in
that kind of inflection, often times you
have to be your biggest critic.
>> Correct.
>> Cuz no one else will do that work.
>> Yeah. It's almost like when things
aren't going well, you have to be your
own biggest fan.
>> Yes. Yes.
>> And when things are going well, you have
to be your own biggest critic. And it's
a very different
>> state of mind to be very different.
Right.
>> Well, and also, you know, and and
especially because like you don't want
to be deputy downer in your company
going, "Wow." But like
>> who else is,
>> right? Right. [laughter]
We're getting these mega valuations.
Everyone loves you. All right. So, one
thing that you brought up that I really
like is this idea of like passion. So,
just because you're growing doesn't mean
you care about your product or your
customers.
And, you know, it was interesting. I
experienced this one personally. There
was this point where Justin TV was
pivoting into Twitch and we went from
kind of more of a general audience,
which
is what it is, to a very specific video
gaming audience, people who are really
hardcore video gamers. And I I liked
video games. I have video game systems,
you know, it's like, but you know, I
remember kind of trying to take stock of
like, is this are these my people? Like,
is this what I'm going to enjoy?
And what was so interesting is that
while on one hand the company was doing
better in some respects than it ever had
been, on the other hand, I kind of was
realizing
I don't know that these are my people. I
don't know that this is something that I
am super passionate about.
>> If you don't care about your customers,
you don't care about the problem, growth
won't, you know, it won't inherently
make you more interest. Sometimes it
does.
>> Sometimes it does,
>> but it won't just solve that issue.
>> Yeah. You know,
>> and you you make a good point about
nuance, right? Like sometimes it does.
>> Yeah.
>> I've been shocked at founders who I
wouldn't expect would be super into this
thing and they they grow into it.
Totally.
>> Yeah. Um but sometimes it doesn't. So
it's a question to ask yourself. One
that I think about a lot is is vision
>> which is
>> I have a lot of positive correlations of
when you talk to founders even at the
early stages
>> they have a picture in their brain of
what their company is supposed to be and
it's a very clear picture and they can
explain it to you versus people where
you ask them for far future expectations
and it just is they don't have a picture
in their brain and so I feel like that's
important to me like with the work that
I'm doing um at standard is I have a
very clear picture about what I want it
to be. I don't I don't know if it'll
work or not, but I can promise you.
>> Yeah.
>> I I can see it.
>> Okay. And so my job is to manifest this
thing I can see in my head. Yes.
>> And this reminds me so much of the
really successful founders. I remember
doing office hours with Tony from Door
Dash when he was in the back. Yeah.
>> And he could explain what Door Dash was
supposed to be
>> perfectly well when it was two months
old. And that's exactly what it became.
It kills me because when you talk to
Tony at various different levels,
he would always refer to Amazon. Yeah.
>> And you would just be like,
>> "Really?" And but then like over the
years, it was like, "He did it."
>> Wow. [laughter]
>> And there was this one point where he
was like, you know, we're n% of Amazon's
daily deliveries. And that was a large
percent. And I remember just being like,
"Oh my god, when you said that, the
other thing that I think about is that
when you have a vision, you almost have
like a philosophy. You have like a weird
explanation about what your customers
want, how you can build a company that
can serve them over a long period of
time. And you can nerd out about your
company in a way that's like pretty
deep." And I will say I think I only
truly had that experience at YC. Yeah.
>> And you know, I remember thinking about
YC as like it's going to be this
100red-year institution. It's going to
be this combination of a university and
a VC fund and a software company. And it
was just like
>> you'd be in these conversations. People
were kind of like, I don't care. Like,
you know, you're going a level deeper
than I care. And it's like,
>> well, it's it's because PG had a picture
in his mind. It was a very clear
picture. You know, like he saw it. And
um I didn't get the sense when you talk
to a lot of investors, they're just
like, "Oh, I have a job and it pays me a
lot of money and like my job is to make
money.
>> Someone else figured out what this VC
business is, you know?" Like they're
just sort of like,
>> "Yeah." Yes.
>> Hey, I'm just happy to be here. And that
was not PG's vibe.
>> Well, and I think that that was what
is so interesting is because
the thing that I would note to the fast
growing startup here is like assume you
have a competitor who thinks like that.
>> Yeah. You want to be able to nerd out
about your business and your vision and
growth doesn't mean it doesn't force you
to have that picture in your head.
That's what we're trying to say is even
if you have a hockey stick graph,
>> it could be you're just drawing a blank
about what this is supposed to turn
into. And I and I worry about those
companies.
>> Yes,
>> there's a lot of folks with hockey stick
graphs. And I think the folks with the
clearest picture are probably going to
win. That's
>> 100% [laughter] and and and I think the
ones who don't really dig in and ask
themselves these questions, what's
interesting is that they end up, you
know, when you hockey stick enough, you
stop competing with little startups and
you start competing with the actual
companies that make up the economy and
they
all all of them have very in-depth
visions. And when you get under their
radar and if you're just like ho hom and
they're like oh yeah part of our vision
is taking the best startup ideas from
this space and just bundling them into
our product [laughter]
>> like certainly a strategy
>> like you're like oh man was all my work
just to further their business model
it's like yeah
>> it was [laughter]
unless you had a vision to compete
against it. Yeah. No we've seen that
time again. One thing we see in
companies that are growing really fast
is they make bad decisions, specifically
hiring decisions.
>> Y
>> and this I think comes from unclear
thinking. You know, it's like
>> it's a disaster,
there's a fire, tell me who the firemen
are. And like when you're an advising
company and be like, there are no
firemen. Like that's not something
people want to hear. People want to hear
if you hire this exact or you hire this
person or you do step one, two, and
three, the fire will go out. as opposed
to hearing
your goal was to to live in the fire
like that. That's what winning looks
like. [laughter]
There's no if the fire goes out, it's a
bad thing.
[laughter]
>> Like Tony is in the fire. Brian Airbnb
is in the fire.
>> Just because it's growing doesn't mean
hiring is easy. Isn't like and it
doesn't mean you're going to make it's
harder cuz when you're not growing, you
don't even have the choice to hire for
the most part, right? Suddenly all these
people who seem impressive want to work
with you. Yeah.
>> And then I remember this conversation. I
have to change the names of the company
slightly, but let's say a friend of
mine. I went to visit their company and
it was a high-flying company. And
I met an employee who didn't realize who
I was or my my relationship with the the
founder. And so they gave me like this
moment of honesty and they were
like,"Ive picked five companies and I
think these are the five kind of winning
companies and my goal is to spend 18
months at each company getting over my
like vesting threshold and I will have
these five." And I'm just like,
>> "Oh, [laughter]
you've really thought this out. I see
you're more of a taker than you are a
contributor." Um, and I was just like,
"Oh, you know that it's easy to miss
those kinds of people when you're
growing fast." Um, and and they come.
Another tricky one, um, that's very,
very tricky is just because you're
growing fast doesn't mean you are
solving your customer's problem.
>> Y,
>> I would say the longer you are growing,
the more evidence is accumulating that
you are solving a customer problem. But
I cannot tell you how many companies,
let's remove AI for a second. Let's just
start to B2B SAS days. I loved asking
people the question, "Oh, great. So,
you've sold this company this number of
seats for your software." It's like,
"Yeah, it's like, wow, great deal." No,
no, no. How many of those people who
have seats go to your product?
>> Oh, man. And that's the They love you
for that question.
>> Well, the best answer is the most
innocent answer, which is like, how
would we know? Like, [laughter]
>> Michael, I've never thought about we got
them. We got the customer, we got the
signed contract. Why would I ask who's
half the seats? Yeah.
>> The kind of darker answer is like when
the founder does know and they're just
like
we're working on retention.
>> We're working on retention. It's like
they already bought the thing. They
don't even want to use it. Like that's a
and so you would be shocked at how often
software is purchased in a company that
no one
wants is told about uses and then how
often it is unpurchased. That is a
standard thing that happens I think
people aren't talked about and so
especially if your company kind of gets
in the zeicist a little bit.
>> Yeah,
>> that's a common common one. Where else
would you go? I think I think my last
one here is it doesn't necessarily solve
the founders's ability to just like deal
with their day-to-day life. And if
they're dealing with other tricky stuff,
>> uh I don't know, like health issues or
or personal issues,
>> growth won't necessarily fix those and
can make them worse. Like if you have st
if there's some like big stressor in
your life, growth won't necessarily fix
that. Well, and what's unfortunate is
that when you're growing, you just have
to put more of your day-to-day resources
towards your company. And so, if you
were just holding on, things are are
tricky. I remember having this
conversation with the former batch
director at YC. And I remember,
>> you know, she was like, "Hey, look, this
growth thing is an emotional struggle.
Startups are emotional struggle." And
you know, it took me a while to think
back and realize that like I'd been with
my now wife during my almost my entire
startup journey.
>> And so it was like I took it for
granted.
>> Yep.
>> Just having that. And like
>> sure helps
>> like I can't even
>> I can't imagine literally [laughter] I
cannot imagine. And so um that's a
tricky thing. Your life gets exposed a
little bit when you're growing and when
your company's demanding more. So
congratulations on the growth.
[laughter]
>> We're excited for you.
>> Growth is good. Growth is the main
thing. We're just trying to flag some of
the stuff that if you're growing well
still is a problem.
>> Yeah.
>> Still is a problem.
>> Ask some of these questions and you know
and on an optimistic note, if you root
out some of these things, you these are
all fixable.
>> Yeah.
>> Like you can fix these things. But if
you put blinders on them,
>> one of them is going to get you.
[laughter]
It's like there's too many stray bullets
around. One of these guys can get you if
you're not looking. If you are looking,
you can work around all of these things.
>> All right, cool. Good chat. Thanks,
Michael.